meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und alle anderen ich begrüße sie recht
herzlich zu einem neuen mal wanne video
bitte schneiden sie sich jetzt an und
aus sicherheitsgründen unterlassen sie
das trinken während der vorstellung da
in der vergangenheit schon viele
tastaturen darunter leiden mussten und
wir diese vorfälle vermeiden wollen und
nun wünschen wir ihnen viel freude beim
blog blog
an unserem vierten tag wurden wir mit
regen begrüßt und wie ihr an meinem
gesicht erkennen könnt ging es mir nicht
allzu gut eine mischung aus klimaanlagen
und klimaanlagen haben mich krank
gemacht und carey hat mir erklärt dass
es keinen zeit gibt zum kranksein a und
dinkel blasig gerade einfach länger
stehen weil der typ im hintergrund sei
es aussieht ihr dürft nämlich nicht
vergessen es hat in strömen geregnet
however wir waren dann wieder mal auf
den weg um einer weiteren kelly
empfehlung zu folgen und ich sag mal auf
dem weg hat kelly eine wichtige
erkenntnis erlangt
[Gelächter]
unser ziel war das weltberühmte rahmen
restaurant im iran
das besondere an diesem restaurant ist
dass man nicht an einem großen tisch
sitzt sondern an einem langen tisch bei
dem man sich links und rechts wände
hochziehen kann falls man seine ruhe
beim essen haben will dann muss das hier
aus
da legt man sieht nicht mal die kellner
weil alles sich ein kleines fenster
passieren
[Musik]
es wird einem natürlich auch geholfen
und dann ist die klappe auch schon
wieder zu ihrer gäste die russen japaner
wissen wie man alkohol macht
[Musik]
so ein richtiger macho durfte natürlich
auch nicht fehlen
[Musik]
die zeit voll helfen es schmeckt auch
genau dann appelliert schon die ganze
zeit die ersten als letztes bekommt dass
man sie schmecken
jaja das nicht jedes andere
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht mehr wie so doch das
essen ging auf meinen nacken und ich
sehe gerade im hintergrund gab es auch
noch diese schalen die ich so super
klasse fand ich habe nur das set gekauft
um selber zu hause rahmen zu machen
verzieren video darüber sehen wollt dann
müsst ihr das in die kommentare
schreiben
und ich war jetzt wirklich auf zu singen
nachdem wir uns im hotel gegenseitig
trocken gerubbelt haben ging es dann
auch schon wieder zum theater also ich
hab meinen heutige freundin kelly wir
gehen jetzt noch mal um den zweiten teil
zu schauen
aber heute gibt es keinen special event
heute ist nur entspanntes gucken und
dann mal los würde ich sagen und
überraschender weise gab es doch ein
special event die beine vergessen wie
sie mit menschen reden kann
warum mit menschen reden weil wir
einfach den hauptcast von dem
theaterstück kennengelernt haben
ich sage euch jetzt kann ich glücklich
sterben und erst am fünften tages und so
richtig klar geworden dass unser hotel
in kenia town steht gemeint
red
what the [ __ ] wie die es sogar kaffee
mit ihren gesichtern dran wenn euch das
nicht reicht sie wäre es denn mit einem
bts buch mit fotos für 24 euro 95
in der ganzen straße hast du bts gesehen
und dann ging es auch schon zu meinem
ersten carrion barbecue falls sie mal in
new york seit geht auf jeden fall zu
diesem laden da kann man blattsalaten
und nudelsalat und lauch salat und bibel
war und dann kommt die kellnerin rubbeln
geben dem stück vertiefen von zwei
gekoppelte dürfen natürlich auch nicht
fehlen und ein dickes stück fleisch und
noch fleischbällchen und noch
mariniertes fleisch und sie grillen das
alles für dich und dann praxis hier auf
dieses salatblatt takyi den zwiebeln
sonst was oben drauf und dann schaffst
du dir das ins maul und es ist verdammt
noch mal so kammer lakers mein gott ich
werde es niemals vergessen
[Musik]
und wie mein opa schon mal gesagt hat
danach braucht man erstmal einen schönen
verdauungsspaziergang das hat er nicht
wirklich gesagt er war pohl er hat etwas
gesagt wie schnipp schnapp schnäppchen
schnell und ich würde jetzt gerne so was
sagen wie und nachdem wir uns 30 salat
fleisch bälle rein gehauen haben sind
wir erstmal zum sport gegangen aber nach
dem essen haben wir uns an die
koreanischen bäckereien erinnert und
haben uns ein das hergeholt
[Musik]
baumkuchen
nachdem ich kenne mal wieder so richtig
hart gesprengt habe haben wir zusammen
den mobility scake ausprobiert ist er
bauen wie es schmeckt ein klassischer
japan sciaroni
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich bin noch nicht ganz dahinter
gekommen warum kelly einmal anschaut
wenn sie sich was in den mund schiebt
[Musik]
was ist dann mit kostenlos
sie haben wir noch mehr geholt
[Musik]
kelly schönen augen kontakt herstellen
und somit hätten wir den shopping kultur
und fuß abgehackt und was fehlt jetzt
noch natürlich dass 08 15 tore programme
new yorker central park elli und ich im
central park eine kutsche im central
park oder am central park und ein teich
im central park und ein großer stein im
central park und manchmal müssen sie
durch die zwei aus block frauen einfach
mal auf eine bank sitzen nachdem ich in
ruhe unterhalten
bei so viel action haben sich karin und
veronika erstmal einen key um 3 uhr
mittags verdient
leicht angedeutet ging es dann zu meiner
ersten u bahn fahrt
[Musik]
ich war komplett überfordert also meiner
bahn experience würde ich jetzt sieben
von zehn punkten geben es ist ein tolles
fortbewegungsmittel new york da die
straßen sehr voll sind da war es ist
auch sehr kompliziert wenn man sich
nicht auskennt da muss man sich im wesen
durch fuchs im oneworld konnten wir dann
über die ganze stadt blicken
[Applaus]
ja
und auf so einer gratis fehler haben uns
dann die freiheitsstatue angeschaut die
wie alle sagen echt kleiner ist als man
denkt beides unser letzter wichtiger tag
in new york city
aber das gute ist welcher heute
geburtstag
heute kann es regnen stürmen und
schneien
denn nicht immer wie ein sonnenschein
heute ist mein geburtstag darum feiern
wir fertigen lassen wir uns heute
tätowieren lassen war und heute
tätowieren wie schön dass es jetzt schön
dass wir ohne tattoos gefahren
denn jetzt können sich ganz an ganz
geschickt kleiner spoiler
ich bin ungefähr ab tag 3 krank geworden
heute also ich bin richtig drauf ein
foto fürs familienalbum und natürlich
findet ihr tattoo bei ok in der infobox
und falls ihr mal in new york seit oder
einfach tattoo inspiration braucht
schaut gerne bei ihm vorbei
[Musik]
doch halt stopp das war noch nicht alles
an meinem geburtstag mussten wir
natürlich noch mal zum kreieren barbecue
gehen und danach zum karaoke
ja baby
[Musik]
duell
[Applaus]
ihr seid da weder sie mit mir diese in
new york verbracht
das war das erste mal dass ich wirklich
meinen kontinenten lassen konnte
dass ihr also bedeutet mir bald auch
wenn ich meine angst hatte und wenn ich
mal ganz verstehe ich steh war und ich
freue mich dass das mit euch gemeinsam
gedacht hab mein gemüse hätte nicht
besser sein können zuschüsse geburtstag
den ich jemals hatte
es ist nämlich egal wie viele gäste
haben nämlich wenn die richtigen werte
da sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
beim 1
[Musik]
ak
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
o
da
[Applaus]
[Musik]
na will
[Applaus]
berlin
[Musik]
der titelsong
mehr
[Musik]
das war die show ins leben